to make the actual making of a film the
day-to-day going to work the
construction of them there's always been
my favorite thing I'm gonna go send them
here my wife's over there watching
reading something understanding the
mirin I'm a practicing move this is
really embarrassing well too bad man do
it the mirror right now the $320 guy was
like usually go because it was so much
fun and I was looking over my shoulder
go on being an actor or even being an
artist and I had studied in school
behind the camera was not even in the
vernacular of my dreams
he's an Academy award-winning American
actor he achieved critical success for
portraying a cowboy who was diagnosed
with AIDS in the Dallas buyers club
movie he also starred in HBO's first
season of True detective for which he
earned an Emmy nomination he's Matthew
McConaughey and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success number one is
my personal favorite and make sure to
stick around all the way to the end for
some special bonus clips also as you're
watching and listening if Matthew says
something that you really enjoy make
sure to leave in the comments below with
quotation marks so we know what you
really enjoy to make the actual making
of a film the day-to-day going to work
the construction of them there's always
been my favorite thing I like making it
feel much more than like watching them I
do and even the ones I'm in I really
love the coming together with a whole
bunch of people having an idea on paper
and everyone's got everyone's an expert
at what they do and your and you're off
on this journey you've got ideas but
then you just let them do let it let it
go and see what it can become
I love the making that's when I'm
happiest is when I'm making a film or
telling the story the day to day and
more so than watching them really the
mean look I kind of define that for
myself about four years ago process
probably stay in process head down in
process stay in your bubble and when
it's over be that fulfillment notice
when I started noticing that fulfillment
of it I just finished well that's enough
that's it I don't know if this thing I
don't know if it's even coming out I
don't even know if I don't know what
it's going to turn in band I hope they I
hope we got it and I hope the director
put something good together
but I don't know nothing I can do about
that all I know is this experience that
I said go have the experience Makani and
if I can love this experience and at the
end of it I'm like may never even hear
that film again may never know that
story again it may be gone we find out
that all the negatives cut fried the
x-ray machine there is no film but I've
got to be that's okay I had an
experience when I got selfish for that
for that experience when I got that
process enjoying that process the day to
day architecture of making a movie and
creating a role that's that's what I've
been the happiest and more results have
come that way in an odd way you know but
I just saw when I started really
approached them as this is a finite
thing and this is just that experience
other than that I'm not producing this
thing I'm not the one editing thing I
don't know what it's going to be that's
it and then all of a sudden they come
out and you go oh I think who's got a
good one
so are you surprised by places you went
in that performance are you surprised
when you see it back or you really have
not out already
not after I engaged and not after I took
the dare as soon as we I got off the
phone call with him and then also when
he said it's not in the picture now but
we think I think it'd be great if Dallas
dance at the end and my heartbeat went
up on the phone I started breaking the
cold sweat like oh no I thought that's
not and as soon as I would all no that's
not that the other other devil in my ear
said dare you do and I just went of
course I think it's yes good idea Matt
immediately knows if you don't you're
pulsing out dude are you kidding me you
will forever regret you have to so soon
as I got over that I was like well
that's inevitable I'm doing it mmm now I
got to bust my ass to go do it the best
I can and a lot of fear that mmm I mean
that was yeah those are those that was a
major really good anxiety and fear and
then now we're saying now I'm saying by
that time now everything my choice is
from that phone call long work anything
I was nervous but you have to go
now to go all the way go meet midnight
yes can y'all meet him for another Korey
choreographed session 8:00 a.m. Sunday
morning do you got an hour
I'm gonna go send them here my wife's
over there watching reading something
I'm standing here and I'm a practicing
move this is really embarrassing well
too bad man do it in the mirror right
now because the less embarrassing that
gets hopefully the more comfortable
you'll be when you're out there in front
of 80 people and bunch of cameras and
one thing you do when you go out there
don't come up short
go all go all the way so even with these
movies under your belts you came out to
LA and you were still thinking it was
gonna be for PA work still thought you'd
be able oh I mean I didn't know we still
I was believing more I mean I sure did
like but I was doing and I had people
and I couldn't you know honestly at that
time the $320 guy was like usually
though because it was so much fun and
and I was looking over my shoulder going
and I kept
like that and then I'd have people come
on over hey man you're good at this
sounds like cool things cuz it sure is
fun um so I really didn't I really
didn't know
I guess secretly if I look back I and I
look at my Diaries ever there was hope
underlying but I was still like I need
to go out and get a job and if I can
pursue acting on the side I get it get a
PA job get the storytelling biz behind
the camera in and let's see and then
another funny thing happened at that
first audition when I got out here was
we're casting a cream Hank McCain hmm
you know talking about use for a film
called boys beside and I went in read
and he goes that's having he did really
good I'll have you for a callback
sometimes I went off from there I get
called in for a baseball film angels in
the outfield I walk in the door this is
this there's a bunch of funny peculiar
how the hell I got to be standing here
today I walk in the door was backlit our
Nevada they l had a American cap on has
on Warner Brothers loud I open up the
door was backlit in the afternoon
producers sitting on the couch he looks
at me Gus hey thanks Jim y'all emerging
did you ever play baseball in 12 years
because she got the job
so they send me like a nice regular
forty-eight five forty eight thousand
five hours of play baseball for 11 weeks
and Oakland again I'm going what is this
business but it it happened and during
that I got called back to read for her
betrothed boys on the side got that role
and so I that that Coen Brothers film
that got pushed that PA job that I would
have taken if it was their never
happened and I haven't PA and I had
about a year and a half I would audition
and I would get one callback two
callbacks three callbacks and I and I
never got the part
and I remember feeling like I'm too
tight you know what I mean I think maybe
I'm studying too much I remember telling
my talk to myself maybe I'm studying too
much about the import of the line and
everything and you know what I think I
need to go back to doing what I did when
I first started which is I was just a
guy and I improvised so I had a head of
film that I was cast for and I was
playing this on the border Mexican
druglord
and I told myself s I'm not going to
look at the side I'm not even gonna read
the script it's an on the border Mexican
drug lord I hear the synopsis if I know
my man then I'll show up and just
obviously I'll read it right before I go
on and if I know my man that'll be like
well that's exactly what he'd say
foolish I go I go I go to set that that
morning all right I'm just gonna all I
gotta do is have a glance at it and
it'll be like yep I know I know how to
do it well I look at it right before
about to to say action and it was a page
and a half monologue in Spanish oh and I
remember I felt this drip of sweat come
up on the back of my head and go down
and out and then for whatever reason I
looked over and I said um kinda okay can
you give me that twelve minutes why I
said twelve minutes I don't know I
figured it was like not long enough to
be inconsiderate but but long enough to
maybe get a little bit of this anyway it
was I think I was horrible in it I
stammered through some Spanish and and
tried to look a line so then I was like
okay that's not the way to go
there's a blend here of having to do
your due diligence do your studyin but
then being able to go there on the day
and relax and throw it all away I'm
probably much more intentional than
people would think I am I make choices I
invest in them I work on them and I
don't shy don't choose to really share a
lot of that it's my own private time I
do it's the I try and do the work
whether it's personally whether it's on
a roll whatever so I can then appear
like a blowing in the wind
alright Crowley I call it create your
own weather so you can blow in the wind
it's that conservative or liberal late
thing going talking about you see what
sandbox you're playing in any glass in
here no no glass okay there's the
boundaries that's the rules okay now get
four-dimensional in the sandbox now blow
in the breeze alright you know give me a
cheese my direction we're going to East
we're going north we're going south and
we going west all right I got it this
character's going east
well now you got 616 lane to swerve in
take an exit like I do all you got to do
to get there you don't know how we're
gonna get there we may have a long pit
stop the gas station we may pull off
somewhere we may stop but one thing
we're not gonna do is pull a u-turn and
go the other way stay in the same
direction and swerve all you want
that's the liberal leg that's the blow
on the wind so I I do my pre-production
or whether it's nearly whether it's in
the window a go with more than appetit
with myself I have a ply make a plan out
but the day of the week a year and then
I kind of set it out there and say now
how we're gonna get there I'm not sure
but it's there and I'm an AG mama happy
to say that so many of my goals and
dreams that I've had 19 out of 20 that I
wrote down in 1988
I completely forgot about him will you
forgot about I pulled a diary out last
year in nineteen out of twenty I've done
and never once remember specifically
saying
do that hmm so it was in there try
somehow is going after me getting them
but I'd never remember trying to go get
him
starting with Lincoln Lawyer was a time
and I said I wanted to recalibrate my
relationship with my career I remember
saying that I remember thinking my
career's I'm enjoying it I love it it's
given me I like going to work I like the
things I've been doing but everything I
saw her reading I felt like Oh leave
it's another version of something I've
done or I feel like I could do it next
week and I remember going wait a minute
before you get mad at thinking you could
do something next week that's a valid
feeling don't just say no to something
cuz you feel like you can naturally do
it but then I said okay fair I'll shake
with you on that McConaughey but let me
find something that I that I don't know
how what to do that next week or the
week after I find something that I
really like but I'm going fool I'm not
sure then that scares me that shakes my
floor and I was fortunate enough um cuz
that schedule F check I got a name is Li
Hao field to know that I my ribs paid I
was fortunate enough know my kids were
going to eat and was just shepherding my
first son into the world so I had that
to take care of my time that's it's a
great time to go into the shadows and be
a be a father and sit back and see if
something turns you on from the inside
or if something finds you if you hear
the target that can draw the uplet's
we're okay
rent paid kids are gonna eat we can take
some time off I know we was thinking
about like oh I'm done but I didn't know
how long the dry spells gonna go so I
said no to some of the things that were
similar to what I had been doing before
and it took a while I had to sit down at
mage and say hey I'm really going to do
this and I need your help with my
commitment to this because after eight
months if I'm the same thing comes in
with a big ten million dollar check it
starts to read better
I just promise you those I mean the same
words son is that's kind of it I think
this thing's I think I can find an angle
no I can make it a different experience
for me so so I said I'm gonna need your
help Punk written down here in in say
notice of things in Selma I need you to
be a gatekeeper one to keep them getting
to me - let's be real clear I'm I'm kind
of looking for some different things to
do he holed up he handled that my wife
who said we don't how long it's gonna be
dry then after they quit sending those
then it did get drivin nothing came for
about a year there's nothing and I
didn't have any sleepless nights or oh
my gosh I was like no I'll find
something I'll write I was writing a lot
I was turning myself on creatively and
as I said I had my first son to Shepherd
into the world and then the funny thing
happened the beautiful thing happened
that that somehow the target drew the
arrow and I think my opinion is I became
a new good idea by being by removing
myself I became win frickin calls
reverse i'm steven soderbergh calls for
the first time somehow in that two years
I became fresh new idea that I don't
think I was too three years prior how
that works I'm not sure because I didn't
send a memo out but it did happen being
an actor or even being an artist and I
had studied in school behind the camera
was not even in the vernacular of my
dreams I was raised 9 to 5 you go to
work your work you work your way up a
scale that's from your old man right
yeah and that was all I was able to even
like I said dream about so the idea of
living life and having a career that was
in the arts that was in the storytelling
business it was something that's really
fun was not something that like said I
even dreamed up I was in the right place
right time right bar guy found me and
said you want to come in and read for a
part in a movie I'm here producing all
Dazed and Confused I said sure I got to
read for the part it's got three lines
three lines turns in three weeks work
they're paying me 325 bucks a day people
are telling me I'm pretty good
and I think I'm getting away with
something and I still do feel like I'm
getting away with how didn't you add
meat always been the most important
thing for me it to be the best man that
I can be and my rights as a human being
more than my rights as a citizen number
two and my rights are my identity as an
American McConaughey what all those
things you break down to family from
from you know child of God if that's how
you see it to be in a human to be in a
citizen to be in an American to be any
McConaughey all those identifications
you get bringing it down to self hmm
those are all come before now I'm a
famous actor hmm
and are now I'm an actor who has become
famous or I am a celebrity celebrity and
famer are amendments that came along the
way were they did they did they all of a
sudden proposed many new challenges with
how to balance like you damn right they
did needed many times I was like God can
I have 26 hours in this day instead of
24 can I just need two more I'm in a one
minute it's all and I'm not sure I'm not
discriminating enough I'm not being
discerning enough I'm kind of everything
sounds good
mmm you know everything was now all the
answers were no yesterday right in this
career I'm taking on in boy over one
weekend everything's yes it inverted ly
flip-flopped yeah mr. dad 99 nose out of
a hundred scripts in over one weekend
after time-to-kill comes out it flips 99
yeses great but hang on a minute I got a
these things that I'm looking at and
going well yes three days ago we
received yes two days I have to be much
more discriminant mm-hmm and really try
to go let me ask myself what is I want
to do that's not easy to do because
there's time this is a netbook and have
26 hours in the day you know I mean what
I'll have it or um disseminating between
them it's walking that line or really
respecting this job that I do as a real
privilege
hmmm that in an honor to do at the same
time
you gotta had to get lit you got to go
from being impressed to getting really
involved and I find that if I can get
really involved that doesn't lessen my
respect for a craft for something I'm
doing it actually raises it because it's
a little more of a sober look at it it's
looking at eye to eye I mean if you
Revere
you're never gonna you never going to be
on you're never going to engage with it
as much because you're always beneath it
you know so to get involved with it
still respect it
don't patronize it come on Senate look
down on it that's not healthy either but
also where you can respect it know it's
a privilege you don't have to don't be
don't be beneath it like oh my god I'm
just so thankful that this is up just
doing no you go look at it level and go
okay well why am I doing this and what
can I give and what can it give me back
there came a time while we were working
I was like okay dead Dallas buyers club
CEO we got to do that later they would
this has it fits in this year and I need
to put it in that slot and was like in
the in the fall you'll be like okay good
it's not real we don't have defined
spoken oh we'll get that look at that I
get that would d'Italia in the fall the
fall and part of getting they did John
Mark he and I me he's interested so some
pieces come together and what we did is
we didn't flinch
once we said we're going to make it in
that fall we never we didn't we didn't
flinch when people go what do you know
you can't you can't you don't have money
for it which we didn't no no no we will
get it it's coming we got it would make
it a fault and we just never flinched
and I and I remember I never had any
doubt I got to talk myself into it
obviously because hello I was wrong I
there wasn't money it caught up with
this like right as we were making it
caught up with us the money fell out
what money was there money had fallen
out of this thing so many times what
money was there and told to be real
turned out to not be real just a few
weeks before we started shooting and
then by that time you know John Mark and
I've been working on the script and I
had already you know I was already into
this into this
guy had lost a bunch weight someone said
we may have to push the spring and I'm
again I didn't know that was ignore not
pushy just spring we're doing it this
fall we're going except the day were
there and something about that and I
wasn't the only one doing that there was
there were there was others to the
producers John Mark something about that
it's weird how some things can get made
in this town by just blindly saying no
it's happening and if you get enough
momentum and don't even consider the
other options because if you flinch if
we deflect and said sorry
even that would have been too much it
would have left a little they were left
a sliver of light open for something to
go okay lease is possible it then it did
the things that happened just probably
would have happened you know so yeah I
said yesterday turn down 86 times I got
corrected last night and turned out the
count real count was it's been turned
down 137 times
Wow so that is like I would what makes
this so much fun yeah this is that you
know we were never after the result with
that just the getting of the getting of
it made was so visceral that but now
it's around it's a year later and you
know the movie translates and then we're
getting it was autumn at the film the
message our roles that makes me very
proud to be here talking about it
because there was so much skin left in
the game by so many people to get it
made to do worse and provide inspiration
for the dazed and confused character is
that true getting ready for that role
the first night I went up for a dress
rehearsal in hair makeup and I stepped
out of the trailer and Rick Linklater
the director comes up because this is
great look like Wooderson this is great
he goes listen man I know you're not
supposed to work tonight but we got to
sing the top notch it's Friday night um
you know what do you think Watterson
might be there you know trolling for
chicks what have you know I mean he goes
I go yeah he would be there and he goes
what do you think would work should
maybe be attracted to the redheaded
intellectual you know cuz Wilson's been
around school he's kind of been with all
the typical beauties what about the
redhead intellectual you think you being
and I was like yeah I said give me 30
minutes let me take a walk and he goes
okay so I took a walk come back i we
played verbal ping pong I told him my
ideas and he told me his he goes once
you did it I went okay so boom we go up
to the set I get in the car and I'm like
I'm nervous first scene ever on film and
right before about to shoot I've got
friends in the car I'm going I've been
listening to this live Mord live doors
out and there's this in between to the
songs more singles all right all right
all right all right
you've heard that recording right before
all right all right all right all right
it's all right for about to go I'm like
what is Waterson what is worse than
about what's he about I go man he's
about four things
he's about you know his car he's back
getting high he's got a rock and roll
and picking up chicks I go I'm in my car
I'm high as a kite I'm listening to rock
and roll action and there's the chick
all right all right
or
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoy I made this video because
Ashe Wilson asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I just love to know which of
Matthew's top-10 rules have the biggest
impact doing why what clip resonated
most with you what change you're going
to make in your business now after
watching this clip leave in the comments
and I will join the discussion also if
you like some of the quotes that people
have left from Matthew from these clips
make sure to show your appreciation by
giving those comments a thumbs up
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Li kun 5 who recently purchased 10
copies of my book 10 copies I really
appreciate that hopefully you can use it
for yourself and give it us some gifts
away to people that will make an impact
for those of you guys who want to change
at a future shout out in a video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon
duskie no thank you though
mister what can I bring for you on this
glorious afternoon
well actor here's the game plan gonna
bring us two Absolut martinis you know
how I like them straight up and then
precisely seven and 1/2 minutes after
that you're gonna bring us two more then
two more after that every five minutes
until one of us passes the bow excellent
strategy sir I'm good for with water for
now though thank you
it's his first day on Wall Street give
him time hmm thank you mm-hmm thank you
mr. Hanna
you were able to do drugs during the day
and then still functions he'll do your
job no else would you do this job
cocaine and hookers my friend right I
gotta say I'm incredibly excited to be a
part firm I mean the clients you have
are absolutely the clients your only
responsibility is to put meat on the
table you got a girlfriend
I'm married I have no wife her name's
Teresa cheek guts here congratulations
thank you think about Teresa name of the
game move the money from your clients
pocket into your pocket right but if you
can make a client's money at the same
time its advantageous everyone them
correct No number one rule of Wall
Street nobody
okay if you're Warren Buffett or if
you're Jimmy Buffett nobody knows if
this stock is gonna go up down sideways
or in circles least of all stockbrokers
right it's all a Fugazi you know what if
a gauzy is well okay z it's a fake every
AZ for gauzy it's a y z it's a woozi
ative fairy dust it doesn't exist it's
never landed it is no matter it's not on
the elemental chart it it's not real
right all right okay stay with me mm-hmm
we don't create we don't build anything
well so if you got a client mm who
bought stock at eight and it now sits at
16 and he's all happy he wants to cash
in liquidate take his money and run home
you don't let him do that okay cuz that
would make it real right no what do you
do you get another brilliant idea a
special idea another situation another
stock to reinvest his earnings and then
to and he will every single time cuz
they're addicted then you just keep
doing this again and again and again
meanwhile he thinks he's getting rich
which he is on paper but you and me the
brokers we're taking home cold hard cash
via Commission month of all right that's
incredible sir I can't tell you how
excited I am
you should be it's two keys to success
in the broker business first of all you
got to stay relaxed yeah
you like good yeah yeah yeah how many
times a week like um three three four
four three or four times maybe I'll pump
those numbers up those are icky numbers
in this racket hi myself I'd at least
twice a day Wow
once in the morning right after our
workout and then once right after lunch
really okay I want to that's not why I
do it I do cuz I need to think about you
you're dealing with numbers all day long
decimal points high frequencies bang
bang bang did you kick it all very
acidic above the shoulders mustard
mm-hmm I got WIC some people out mm-hmm
right you got to feed the geese to keep
the blood flowing I'll keep the rhythm
below the belt done this is not a tip
this is a prescription trust me if you
don't you will fall out of balance split
your differential and tip the [ __ ] over
or worse yet I've seen this happen
implode no I don't want to implode sir
no oh you don't I'm in it for the long
run you know yeah implosions are ugly
yeah pop off to the bathroom work one at
any time you can and when you get really
good at it
you'll be stroking it you'll be thinking
about money second key to success in
this racket is this little baby right
here it's called cocaine right it will
keep you sharp between the ears it'll
also help your fingers dial faster and
guess what that's good for me yes sir
revolutions you follow revolutions keep
the clients on the Feres will and goes
the park is open 24/7 365 every decade
every goddamn century that's it
name of the game
how kitty hmm with a common denominator
CEO oh the money comes in parade comes
town going down Broadway it's a one-way
street whichever way I go can you tell
us anything about that mr. Koch yeah it
looks a lot like the one from 95 where
he knew that already
yeah there's specifics consistent to the
95 case details they weren't public
knowledge
you often grid for eight years right
show Mike up in 2010 my question is how
could it be him
we already caught him in 95
Allen d-detective I figured you'd be the
one to know
and start asking the right questions
and
woodruff you gives me for a moment I
know this can be a very scary thing I
know you're probably feeling overwhelmed
right now but what we would like to do
is to impress upon you the gravity of
your situation based on your health
based on your condition based on all the
evidence we have
we estimate you have 30 days left to put
your affairs in order
30 day I'm sorry
this entire need a mother
let me he we already know you flash I
need nothing out there can give Ron 100
in 30 days